what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and as
you can see i am currently not home i'm
not in my normal setup so i apologize
for this background right now but i just
watched hawkeye the first two episodes
and i gotta say
i was actually kind of impressed um not
gonna lie i didn't know what to expect
going in um
didn't think it was gonna be
mind-blowing by any means
but was pleasantly surprised and uh i
this is just a reaction it's not a
review can't do a review yet i think
that lives in like a couple of weeks but
today the the reaction embargo lifted
but i will say this the opening of the
first episode of hawkeye is one of the
best marvel openings that i've seen i
think um i thought it was really really
cool and i can't obviously give any
spoilers about it but i
i definitely thought it was really
really cool i liked the story a lot it
was different than i kind of thought it
was going to be but it's really really
cool hawkeye is a character that i think
deserves more attention
and he's a very grounded character and
you know the story is kind of taking us
into
who hawkeye is and it's pretty cool to
see and who kate bishop is and haley
seinfeld is just
i think she does an incredible job i
think she's fantastic and of course
jimmy renner just crushes it and
what else could you expect from him but
i think a lot of people are really going
to like hawkeye it's very intriguing
it's captivating it seems to have a good
initial start with its story and there's
a lot of questions that you have which
always make for you know good
storytelling and i think as things
unravel because i've only seen the first
two episodes but as things unravel i
think it's gonna get like pretty juicy
like already it's it's pretty good it's
pretty good i do like the scenes that
they've shown so far with the action
with all the bows and the fighting with
the swords i kind of like how they're
telling everything
kind of back in the hawkeye's past
that's all i'll really say about that i
don't want to say too much but i know a
lot of people were really excited for
this show and i think you're not going
to be disappointed at all i think uh if
you were really excited for the show
it's going to be really good for you and
i think if you're kind of like on the
fence like i was i think you'll be
pleasantly surprised and i think you're
going to enjoy the show as well i
do think as a more grounded show like a
show that's like you know not loki
not one division a lot of magic and
stuff happening but like real real
things going on i think they do an
incredible job and i'm glad they
actually chose hawkeye because for going
for more grounded things what character
is better than hawkeye himself pretty
you know kind of the most grounded
character there is and there's some
funny scenes in it it's really good the
chemistry between haley steinfeld and
jeremy renner is really really good um i
think they're going to be a great duo to
watch on screen with lucky the doug the
pizza eating dog who
is awesome and i swear i'll call john
wick or go jump with myself if that dog
dies sometime in the series because uh
uh the dog's my favorite character but
unfortunately i can't say much it's just
a reaction and my initial reaction is i
really like the show i liked it a lot
and i didn't know
if i would i thought it might be just
kind of like right in the middle but i'm
actually no i'm more towards it's
actually you know a good show and i'm
gonna be really excited to watch this
show of course we'll be doing the live
streams again the live watch parties and
discussions afterwards so that's going
to be really fun to do i think this show
will raise for some really fun
discussions we'll race for some pretty
good breakdown videos and overall i just
think it's going to be a really fun show
that i think people are really going to
enjoy so
not too much longer to wait i think only
like a couple weeks now
um and i think people are going to like
it so look out for my full review when
the review embargo drops in the meantime
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you can stay up to
date on all the latest mcu videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter don't forget to
hit the like button and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you